as a whole as a club the only person
you'll go to mad is stephen channel i
would be really disappointed that mighty
liverpool can't throw another name
and i'd be disappointed that you haven't
got one player who's better it's bad
i've got all the players multiple
players better than him over the years
of course who
is better than right now you are smoking
stuff you should be smoking
bruno fernandez yeah bruno fernandez's
better than gerard yeah go on based on
what
[Music]
it tells me everything i need to know
about it it doesn't it does tells me
everything i need to know nothing more
dangerous than a sober man mine united
are a bigger club liverpool
three two
one
i'll let you start it hurts me to do it
but i'm not going to sit here and just
lie for the sake of it yeah you're
bigger than us right now whether it
remains that way time will tell i know
you're going to say it's always going to
be like that but back in the 80s i could
have turned the question around and said
no you want me bigger than us and you
turned out to be bigger than us
right now you are
in terms of success recent success we've
got that but that doesn't accomplish
everything it takes to be a bigger club
so
i'll give that one to you right now yeah
i i i respect you honestly i wasn't
expecting that i thought i was gonna
have to straight from the off this is
gonna start putting you to the sword
what what i would say is is that you
don't you're not far over i'll let you
know that because it's
still over i know about yours yours is
way over there i send a pint to the
toilets
i'll save it that way yeah
you're talking about last season we had
a better season than usually as good as
your last season let's not talk about
recent history in terms of everything
put together we are the bigger club we
are and i think that our fan base will
demand that we remain that way so i
don't see a change in
any time soon i'm actually concerned
about a little bit so i think you're
concerned about us yeah and why is that
i'm concerned
i mean is is it concern or is it not
explaining
why would you be concerned because every
every every uh great champion great team
needs a rival and you're our biggest
rival but i look at you at the moment
and i think you're absolutely broke
i don't know
based on
last season they're tired they're
knackered we're tired but how many
injuries they're not good how many
injuries because you're tired only time
will tell but for you to sit here and
say we're burning out bro i think you're
burning up you've got but you've got
nothing i told you
but you've got no
about the fact that you are not bringing
any players in i mean you know what no
no i'm not sitting here saying i'm not
concerned we're gonna get the right type
of quality yeah but to sit here and say
we're broke we're not broke but we're
the fifth richest club in the world you
don't know what's going on behind closed
doors if they had money
the intensity that your team were
playing at previously and the trophies
you won incredible absolutely amazing i
look at them last season and i think
they've got to a point where the money
hasn't been spent that starting eleven
is knackered they're looking for
reinforcements on the bench you guys
don't have the reinforcements within
your squad and you are going to struggle
that's my opinion there's a difference
between having a lack of depth and being
burnt out though we're not burnt out we
have a knackered question who's the
bigger club
anfield's atmosphere is better than all
traffic
easy-peasy
[Music]
moving further along do it i know you
want it
the other way come on be better than
that do it
play ludos
i tell you what i tell you what floor's
yours you explained why you did it to me
before go for it uh
listen
say loud we can't hear you i don't know
what atmosphere you want to hear go and
say it loud and proud and i'll tell you
the reasons why
an ultimately leaky roof is at the leaky
roof is that way one of the reasons why
you go to apart from under the clock era
you've had sweet fa to to cheer about so
all they can do is go there and sing to
give them a reason to go back for me
it's
it's a choir opportunity i can't that's
the reason that they go there
the issues with old trafford is that
number one because of the size of the
stadium because of the size of the
stadium it's difficult to create an
atmosphere it's just not quite as
enclosed okay so i would say that's the
reason why you have so successful
a slight advantage in that so that's
that's what i'm going to find out how
big when believing that old trafford
don't tell me there's atmosphere no no
no i'm not i'm just asking because
you're right you're right it's acoustic
it's acoustics nothing to do with
singing or anything maybe the sound's
going through a roof as well isn't it
possibly yeah yeah i just think you guys
are quiet that's fair enough i mean you
say we only sing because there's nothing
to sing about you've got loads of things
to sing about you still don't know we do
say i told you i'll tell you what
because of the song
outside the stage
in the country that's the issue you're
really loud outside the stage with the
protesters
i wasn't submitted
he's making this happen i didn't want to
submit against anybody
paul schools was a better player than
steven gerrard nudist was coming three
two one
i want this to fall off the edge
would you like me to start would you
like me to quote all the world-class
players in history that i've quoted
all this oh you would also i'm going to
use your argument
unbelievable unbelievable if he was
not
english
he would be respected in a whole
different light of course because he's a
ginger from salford it doesn't get put
in the same bracket as some of the best
players
in history all schools is absolutely
phenomenal okay how many individuals
let's go again
how many how many individual accolades
paul scholes one we're talking about
trophies because no no no no no i know
no i said individual accolades people
felt sorry for him in that liverpool
team they felt sorry for him he was a
shining lightning
mediocrity are you gonna answer the
question oh they'll they'll toss him at
their player of the month they'll toss
him the
player of the season or whatever because
he's carrying a great club that wasn't
delivering something to be probably if
scholes is this all-worldly player why
doesn't he want any individual accolades
of course he's one individual how many
and he's won multiple titles one
champions league asking about titles and
championships gerald won a champion when
it's all said and done lucky a trophy
cabinet he continually delivered titles
year after year
to do this
so it was him by himself is he roger
federer now is this he's he's a massive
part of the reason why courses and
gerald was massive part of the reason
why when a champions league why won
every trophy apart from the premier
league he didn't win it yes he you're
right he didn't because he didn't have
the team around him
he's not a better player
all right go on what's the next
attribute you want first touch scottish
is whoever you want whatever you want i
can go general now i'm going to go
gerald on that one if you're just going
to be unrealistic what's the point why
is it being so name your research why is
it unrealistic why is it unrealistic
that's your answer every time that you
want to see schools no it's not of
course it so you're telling me jared is
a rubbish long-range suitor
like an assist don't even speak to me
about assists because salty nose lolsy
when was the last time skulls an assist
megs let's talk nutmegs skulls about
nutmeg why is this street fifa who cares
about that mix that's all about the
whole aspect of it the skill set scholes
is a better no
overall than steve jones is a better
goal scorer
yes fat i'm name in fact your name in
nostalgia debatable it's not debatable
look at the records i'll let you after
would you go off something
i've already got i know you have that
it's tackling yeah because heading red
card schools yeah i'll definitely
hmm gerard
possibly oh do me a favor
you're better than this
definitely yeah i think scores is a
better player than stephen i'm saying a
phenomenal player but he's not better
than jerrod
as a whole as a club the only person
you'll go to mad is stephen channel i
would be really disappointed that mighty
liverpool can't throw out another name
and i'd be disappointed that you haven't
got one player who's better that's bad
i've got older players multiple players
better than him over the years of course
who
bruno fernandez is better than right now
you are smoking stuff you should be
supposed to
look at looking bruno fernandez yeah
bruno fernando is better than gerard
yeah go on based on what take away
penalty goals as well go on
well china did take penalties
not as many as bruno takes
can't we it's not our fault
you're diving we're going it's just how
fast our front three what is
i thought you know what ollie's gone
this team's in a whole world of trouble
steven jarrett couldn't have that impact
on that team
you're joking so hold up gerard playing
for liverpool he shouldn't have been
anywhere near the champions league won
it in 2005 against one of the greatest
assembled teams to play in the final but
yeah bruno fernandez came in off the
back of a burnley win but he's better
than gerard i think
i think the way he's lifted our team and
galvanized our team
yeah to what finishing above you
finishing second yeah so this is this so
you've got a player
you won no this is the beginning of
school you keep winning
this conversation in four or five years
and i think the trophies will be in the
cabinet you keep talking about second
place you keep on saying bruno has come
in and galvanized a team but to what
second place he's galvanized the team to
second place we were six or seven we
were we were languishing like you were
last season that's where we were
jeremy's coming
for us
bruno what did bruno do in the last
final it's about time what did he do in
the last time and he will he will win
trophies with us i fully believe it but
you're saying he's better than gerald
right now based on what i think the way
he came into starting steve and janna
wouldn't be able to do that that's my
statement you're crazy i'm not get me an
arsenal fan
this is ridiculous
virgil bandai is better than the manual
village
three
two one
move it go on move it move it take the l
take the armor
take the l
we're not going to call you jordan we're
going to call you lord and take the l
take the l
don't do this yourself don't embarrass
your fanbase and don't embarrass
yourself be better there we go there we
go
oh that was nice
i'll let you explain first
very few words
it's really quiet there can you speak up
for me please join me you know what i'll
tell you what is uh
van dyke is a very very special defender
um never gets dirty i signed up a good
defender we have one of those for real
but
the way
klopp looked at that team and realized
what he needed to sign
where he came from and then was able to
raise his game i always say that you
know for man united and liverpool
there's a certain pressure playing for
those clubs more so than any other clubs
because of the history and that's why
you know over the years we've both
signed big players with big reputations
they've gone in and they haven't been
able to deliver because the pressure's
too much fun he's gone into our team
lifted it and won the biggest trophies
so for me
it hurts but yeah i think he's uh an
outstanding outstanding defender and i'd
love to have him jordan that was
fantastic
absolutely loved every second of that
leave it
he's just better in it everything
literally don't don't push it up no but
i just want to go for the action we're
not going through the attributes you
sure listen let's have a bit of fun i've
got a timer and i'm running out of time
no just let's do it
no no
what do you want i've accepted it it's
not i'm going to get pounders from my
old fans
it's still in the middle let me live
he's still in the middle jordan
who came up with that
outrageous
outrageous the european super league was
an embarrassment to both pods
three
two
one
disgraceful so hold on why is it more
over my side because i'm chasing you
side by side strength in numbers
okay middle
as fans
put badges to a side yeah we agree that
football should be the winner and that
wasn't the right thing precisely what
annoyed me the most is that we were the
two clubs at the forefront as well yeah
that's disgusting very much so um
american oldest
i'm glad we came together on that one
yeah definitely definitely it's the only
thing we'll come together yeah and
that's why the glasses are side by side
for the only time today
and for the rest of history
pleasure
is it truly that you don't celebrate
when harry kane scores written
oh i saw those two that was ridiculous
no i don't i don't want it
i'll tell you what i've got
all right
can't believe why is it because i would
go mental if sakura's got the winning
goal
what about seoul campbell scored
but kane didn't leave him
excuse me but now he's club over country
like i mean